enfants samedi soir tf1 diffusait un
nouveau numéro de masques singer mais
qu'est ce que c'est que cette émission
à la base il s'agit d'un format coréens
dont le concept d'enfantin 10 stars
doivent se cacher sous des costumes et
interpréter des chansons avec une voix
plus ou moins transformés
[Musique]
grâce à des indices un jury doit tenter
de découvrir qui se cache sous le masque
mais vous êtes cuit mais vous êtes cuits
ensemble un jeu racheté par hervé hubert
qui produit déjà les rênes du shopping
et à dater sauce française sauf que
voilà en france le concept a été quelque
peu modifié
car si côté star on s'attend à voir ça
au final on se retrouve avec ça les
frères bogdanoff scientifique et
animateur télé
pourtant tf1 n'a pas hésité à mettre les
moyens financiers dans l'adaptation de
ce format chaque prize coûte 1 3 million
d'euros un prix si élevé que le
programme proposé dans un premier temps
à france 2 a été refusé par la chaîne
pour des raisons financières
et ce ne sont pas les célébrités caché
dans le costume qui coûte si cher ce
sont les costumes eux mêmes avec des
coûts de fabrication allant jusqu'à 68
euros par costumes
bref des costumes pas toujours facile à
assumer des sarts pas toujours connus
alors selon vous est ce la honte de
participer à masquer ligue 1 liane foly
qui a quitté l'aventuré samedi soir est
avec nous pour en parler
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
yann folie que j'aime et déjà yann avant
que tu réponds mais dire quelque chose
sur toi parce que yann maintenant je te
connais assez bien et liane foly alors
je vous ai expliqué yann foyer pense
qu'un truc c'est s'éclater moi je les
appelais pour faire la grosse rigolade
elle m'a jamais parlé ni d'argent ni de
truc si ça me fait rire je suis là si ça
me fait marrer si j'ai envie d'être avec
des fiches avec des potes et ben ça me
fait marrer je suis là eliane vraiment
moi j'ai pu j'ai pu m'en rendre compte
avec moi à chaque fois c'est juste
est-ce qu'on va rigoler est ce que tu es
là est ce qu'on va être entre potes
elle n'est pas du tout dans le truc
c'est combien qu'est ce qu'on va faire
tu m'a jamais demandé il ya combien
c'était qu'il y avait et les contrats
les trucs elles sont fous totalement et
c'est peu dire aussi que j'ai quelqu'un
qui s'en dit non mais non mais chacun sa
maison mère à miami nous a souri route
était vraiment mais c'est la règle c'est
vrai c'est vrai et puis il faut quand
même surtout dire quelque chose c'est
que ça fait quand même 30
plus d'une trentaine bonne trentaine
d'années maintenant que je fais partie
d'une troupe dont qui s'appelle les
[ __ ] oui et alors si je devais comme
ça regardez tous les déguisements
si je savais et puis mais c'est une
histoire ça ça c'est un vrai rapport
familiale et et de coeur c'est pourquoi
tu l'as fait 1 parce qu'en fait parce
que y avons déjà c'est mon métier
oui mais oui mais là je veux dire je
chantais franchement oui c'est vrai que
par rapport au reste du casting comme
dans cette liste a été un petit peu
voilà un petit peu la star war moi je
trouve pas je trouve que vous êtes un
petit peu dur parce que chercher ça me
fait plaisir pour oublier ça et tu sais
quoi pourquoi qu'on est potes et donc
donc en fait ce que je voulais dire
c'est que moi je suis toujours
émerveillé par ce qui est enfantin parce
qu'ils nous ramènent à l'enfance parce
que et puis notre métier et notre milieu
est difficile il est
il est souvent très négatif il est vrai
que je suis différente mais c'est vrai
alors on me dit souvent oui les années
différents oui je suis différente et je
revendique ma différence
elle vient de mon enfance j'ai des
parents qui m'ont élevé comme si on
avait été aux états unis ou à toute
petite à 5 ans je faisais tout tout tout
je faisais de la danse je me déguisais
jeu mais voilà ça t'a fait kiffer quant
au top mais oui parce que mes parents
ils avaient une droguerie que ça peut
être gagner serait un grand bazar comme
ça à lyon il vendait des panoplies et
c'était mon jeu préféré
et mon père imeem il mettait des mâles
comme ça entière de d'exaucer va avec
tes amis va jouer et c'était mon premier
jeu en fait
et puis là il ya quelque chose de moi
j'ai découvert cette émission aux états
unis moi j'ai ma famille alors la zone
couriot à la base après après les tarifs
voilà exactement
eh oui de quoi là bas mais après moi je
les ai découverts avec mon frère
philippe paquette à los angeles et ont
fait et là j'ai trouvé ça merveilleux
quoi je me suis dit waouh
ces baignoires ce dégoût venu je vous
dise liane foly et je vous dire
l'émission franchement voilà je
comprends pas tellement navré mais en ce
moment moi je trouve que ma singer ça
fait du bien c'est messi est lente à oui
c'est comme ma singer et ses com alors
en ce moment je trouve que ça fait du
bien
et voilà après on voit la bayard landes
on en a parlé un instant ils ont tenté
mais si j'avais été un truc vraiment
festif tout ça serait des indics l'as
des royals en deux parties peu
angoissant plus avec les poupées dieu
qui les déguisements les zombies poussa
les zombies voilà c'est essayer en ce
moment voilà c'est pas mon truc mais
voilà moi ce qui me dérange dans ce
programme
c'est pourquoi passer son temps à
essayer d'utiliser sur le fait qu'il ya
des stars internationales
ici non assumée par tf1 moi c'est ce qui
me dérange le puits premier jour c'est à
dire qu'ils y passent leur temps à
attiser en disant est ce que c'est
madonna lady gaga enfin soyons pas
ridicule assure bien qu'aujourd'hui
d'experts international ne viendrait pas
joué le jeu elles viennent d'envoyer
n'assume pas été signés et c'est ça le
problème de tf1 pourquoi il n'assume pas
tout simplement que c'est un programme
festif mais pour les jeunes par des que
les laits les stars françaises où les
voeux des noës il se joue et je tiens ce
serait formidable qu'ils me la sucent et
touche assez d'accord je serais d'accord
mais voilà après ce que j'ai aussi ça
fait marrer mois quand ils disent voilà
des grandes stars mais c'est vrai qu'au
liane pour le coup mais c'est un casting
très fort mais pourquoi une pieuvre
l'yonne alors bon bah parce que parce
que j'ai une vanne
à donges en temps mais l'autre les
premiers le nom parce qu'en fait simon
et c'est très drôle parce que la nuit
avant que j'allais les voir pour
l'essayage des costumes j'ai rêvé d'
avatar et moi j'adorais dans le
cinquième élément comme ça d'ailleurs
c'était maïwenn qui jouaient là leur
club comme ça et en fait parce que la
pieuvre elle et il paraît qu'elle est
sage et qu'elle est multipay qu'elle à
plusieurs via bâle a peur et donc ils se
pensaient les cordes aaa à mon arc etc
mais au niveau des mariages la castagne
on l'appelle la preuve est en fait c'est
quelque chose de spirituel
ah oui car on en a parlé ensemble de ça
alors pour moi c'est aussi angoissant je
suis pas d'accord avec vous c'est aussi
angoissant que beauregard langue parce
que pour moi c'est l'émission la plus
angoissante du monde lisse passe rien
les chanteurs ne chante pas en live je
vois pas du tout le côté artistique et
pour moi vous avez posé une question est
ce que c'est la honte ou pas pour les
célébrités
c'est seulement pas la honte quand c'est
yann folie parce que c'est justement
elle qui relève parce qu'elle est là ce
soir non non non non comme ça et là
aussi c'est patrice et elle tue relève
le truc des grandes stars c'est une
grande star on lance sheila dieu sait qu
elle qui relève le niveau et c'est pour
ça que je pense que ce serait bien que
la prod les prévienne parce que je sais
qu'ils les prennent pas de qui à bout
dans le casting je pense pas qu'il y en
ait qui aurait participé
jean-michel bêtement je vais dur vient
de folie que j'aime beaucoup ma mariage
décès de m mais d'un point de vue une
médias j'ai plus de respect pour mac
lesggy qui fait une pub pour les brosses
à dents que pour quelqu'un qui se
déguise qui acceptent de se déguiser
pendant un mois en boule pour la réunion
niang tout ça pour payer ses impôts n'y
a pas de performance artistique c'est
bien que d'accord aujourd'hui a produit
la production la voix est truqué en
enregistrons studio donc ya pas de bien
folichon de très bien une limite très
bien et elle est intelligente elle est
trop le tout ce qu'on veut mais vous
n'êtes pas mis en valeur enfin vous avez
on n'a pas exploité notamment dans cette
émission harding ils ont alors que vous
répondez à ces alarmes et je suis prête
à répondre à jean michel avec plaisir je
comprends très bien tous les arguments
que chacun pourra amener dans vos
critiques
je les comprends incomplète mais
j'assume très fort ce que je fais de ma
vie ma vie j'ai décidé vous savez quand
j'ai commencé ma carrière j'étais dans
une maison disque très branché
qui s'appelait virgin il n'existe plus
d'ailleurs depuis qu'il est parti sur la
lune et donc je dire à un moment donné à
un moment donné c'est thomas interdit
moi quand j'ai démarré ma carrière de
faire patrick sébastien le grand
carnaval on m'a interdit de faire pascal
sevran
parce qu'il fallait pas les dans ce
genre d'émission parce que j'étais une
chanteuse de jazz que que c'était voyez
vous savez il ya toujours des barrières
et des mois je vous laisse j'ai dû me
disputer au sein de ma maison de disques
à l'époque pour dire non je ferai tout
on fait de la musique et on fait une
carrière artistique pour le public et
donc je comprends très bien que sacha
d'air mais mois déjà dans ma vie j'ai
pas de barrière moi quand je vous
regarde le soir tous ensemble oui je
vous que je vous aime je
j'essaye de comprendre pourquoi vous
dites des choses parfois moi qui n'ont
aucun sens et de la foi qui sont
brillantes lumineuse et il faudra me
dire tiens mais qui amène de l'usagé
veut dire pourquoi vous êtes là pour ce
prix vous allez dire pourquoi vous êtes
là j'essaye de comprendre quoi vous êtes
là ah oui et vous et non à ce que vous
vous essayez toujours de comprendre mais
parfois il ya des choses qu'on ne vous
comprends pas moi je vais vous dire que
j'assume que vous pouvez mais alors me
dire tout ce que moi j'adore ça et que
il a du coeur de diable m
radieuse et je prends très bien les
choses et ne t'en fais pas jean-michel
j'ouvrirai bientôt une belle du scrutin